[Music]
Chargers have made it official and they
even have a new logo the LA chargers we
saw that the letter from the owner to
the fan base as well say goodbye
basically he's Dan Fouts the former
charger quarterback Hall of Famer and he
joins us on the program and he surprised
with this news dan well I think it's
fake news you'll be due yeah I just
can't be real okay there's nothing you
made up no no no one me okay well I
don't like it well you bummed out yeah
it's a gut shot it really is you know
having spent 15 years there and been
associated with the associated with the
team for you know 20 odd years
afterwards and doing their preseason
games and whatnot you know it's just
hard to imagine this great city of San
Diego not having the charges would be a
part of it how did we get to this point
well it's like any negotiation and and
you know I think that both sides have
enough responsibility in this situation
and the charger civic leadership over
the last decade has been less than ideal
tough to get a deal made with them by
the chargers but times have changed and
you know money is is that the root of
all of this and obviously that's what
basically it came down to for the
chargers and you know you always hear
that term well the NFL is business well
it is and that's where we are yeah the
problem I have with it I know it's about
business but it's about business that
placates 32 owners and then it trickles
down from there at some point I was
hoping the NFL would say we want to be
in business with San Diego we think it's
best for us we think it's best for those
fans it's you know it's a 40 year
relationship or whatever it is with San
Diego you know at some point you know
does that supersede greed here or you
know some kind of everybody's going to
make money here
but yeah you know that's why it's such a
hollow feeling is that you know where
are we is it is it all just about the
dollars and apparently it is on both
sides i mean the city was unwilling to
give enough to the charges the charges
are willing to even go out and look for
investors and accept you know the from
the link themselves and kind of going
with hat in hand to the league and
saying we want more money well you know
there's 31 other owners are saying hey
wait a minute what a bad precedent that
would be so here we are what if Philip
Rivers doesn't want to relocate and play
in Los Angeles I think he's on record as
saying he didn't want to you know move
to Los Angeles well years under contract
and I don't think he has much say in the
matters anybody that's under contract
has to live up to it or retire me has no
choice to go anywhere unless the charges
can move them in a trade and then this
is what I don't know if this was ever a
possibility but if it felt like the
Raiders if we were going to have a
second team and be the Raiders in Los
Angeles on San Diego and that San Diego
if you're going to relocate Las Vegas
made more sense than then having the
Raiders go there what are your thoughts
on that well the Rangers have a
tremendous fan base in Los Angeles idiom
and a lot better fan base that they're
going to have in Las Vegas a guarantee
of that you talk about it a trenchant
see where the visiting team fans will be
flooding that stadium much as they did
last couple years in San Diego because
it's a destination resource type of town
obviously it's Vegas and people want to
go to Vegas okay let's let's go to the
later game clues so it'll be a fan base
there but it won't do the passionate
fans that the Raiders have in Los
Angeles and is of course the passionate
long-suffering fans in Oakland when you
play this did you realize how much the
Chargers were like nationally the style
the look everything about the Chargers
were cool well you know yes yes I
learned more about that since I retired
because wondering what you would you're
playing
you in the moment you're worrying about
you know who's going to pick up the
Blitz on third and ten but but since
that time you know people say boy
especially people in these clothes that
would tune in at four o'clock to watch
the west coast game and it happened to
be the chargers and those times with
coryell and and the great players we had
in the style that we had it really as
you said Dan people learn were drawn to
it you know the uniforms had something
to do this but the style of play also
was a big factor we talked about this
earlier in the show if you had one drive
of all the playoff quarterbacks is it
obvious who you would take as your
quarterback for that final drive feeling
ever Darren bringing Tom Rogers who
would think if there's one play I want
bread on Rogers this is one drive our
third baby but I don't know what the
difference is there but you look at you
know Hall of Fame quarterback but what
we see with Rogers how unique is that
style it is so unique and if you watch
him throw watch his feet sometimes there
are so many times when he is off the
ground throwing the ball and it's not
jumping up in the air anything it's just
his style of of being on his toes and
the quick release I mean to meee throws
the football as if it were a softball
with absolutely tremendous zip and quick
arm movement so I just love watching him
play I've watched him play since he was
a cow and I just think he's awesome you
know one thing then if you remember back
to the fail Mary in Seattle that alley
that he'll marry that was called by the
replacement officials as a touchdown
really was an interception yeah how the
Packers done since then with the hell
marry pretty good I football karma there
but I'm also I how did the scouts miss
on Rogers that he went to the end of the
first round like what was it that they
had questions about Rogers that they you
know you go in with Alex Smith is number
one quarterback and alex is proven to be
a good quarterback
but here's Rogers who is sort of
transcendent here with what he's done
yeah the only thing that I can remember
is that this is the style that he had
when he played for Jeff Tedford a cow
who was very robotic and even though it
meant for the day today that you know he
held the ball high got it out quick but
it just looked very robotic and it
looked like it wasn't really reading the
defense's it was just one receiver and
get the ball to him it that was the only
negative that I heard about Rogers and
if that made me think back to a game
against SC when that robot completed his
first 22 passes it's okay he stands
found to the Hall of Famer before I let
you go if the LA Chargers reach out and
say would you be part of festivities
opening day calling tall and sending it
will you be associated with the LA
Chargers remember the movie Jerry
Maguire yeah show me the money baby what
if there's no money attached in I'm
sorry are you breaking down my god hey
it's great to talk to you again and
thanks for joining us in always a
pleasure hi at San found her charger
quarterback the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
[Music]